[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ghislain veut
de président du cran le conseil
représentatif des associations noires de
france bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés nadir caillat président de
l'association banlieues plus mon soir à
vous aussi merci d'être avec nous un mot
tout d'abord pour avoir votre sentiment
sur avec les mots font mal à on l'est on
les entend dans cette vidéo de la
violence gratuite pour vous tout
simplement du racisme bête et méchant
geste nerveux 2 tout d'abord il faut
dire qu'il ne faut pas l'amalgamme pas
là ma gamme
il faut pas opposer aussi ici les
communautés et pour parler crûment il ne
faudrait pas opposé des noirs et des
arabes
il faudrait il faut d'abord saluer la
dignité des personnes qui se sont
réunies à cergy hier et il faut dire que
ces personnes étaient de toutes les
couleurs ces personnes étaient blanches
elle était noire elle était d'origine
nord africaine
donc il ne faut pas un amalgame ensuite
il ya deux problèmes le problème
le premier problème est celui des
travailleurs ce qui sont exploités par
le réseau hubert à un moment il faudra
parler de ce problème là parce que
normalement tout employeur doit protéger
ses salariés ça ce premier problème donc
un salarié a été agressé et donc son
employeur devrait le protéger
deuxième problème bien évidemment ces
propos racistes et on ne discute pas
avec des propos racistes
on les condamne et donc ce monsieur a
été retrouvé et le cran est en train
d'agir pour porter l affaire en justice
et être partie civile parce que c'est la
justice qui doit sanctionner ce là votre
réaction nadir khayat parce qu'aux liens
entre voilà on a du mal à trouver les
mots mais entre voilà violences entre
les communautés étrangères on appelle ça
comme on veut mais enfin on va en parler
mais ce débat il vient pas des médias on
va le voir
dans la bouche des responsables
politiques on va parler aussi l'histoire
mais en fait votre premier sentiment
après en tout cas ce cette vidéo assez
choquant il faut bien le dire
ben tiens je suis un peu comme tout le
monde on est tous été choqué par la
teneur des propos et la violence qui a
subi ce pauvre livreur je pense que
c'était le deuxième cette semaine
malheureusement il ya eu deux trois
livreurs hubert qui ont été violentés
par des individus qui sont
principalement des personnes vivant dans
les quartiers populaires et s'est livré
re même sur des personnes très souvent
issus des quartiers populaires donc ça
c'est extrêmement dommageable
après il ya il ya eu des propos qui sont
violents parce qu'il sait pas pour
assises qui ont été tenus envers cette
fable il ya eu cette violence vis-à-vis
du chauffeur donc je pense que tout le
monde condamne ce type de propos cette
violence après je ne pense pas qu'il ya
de tabou en france simplement il ya des
sujets qu'on qu'on parle qui ne sont pas
mis en avant comme d'autres parce que il
ya des racismes qui sont puissants plus
important plus fort et plus plus visible
mais il ya aussi des racismes comme là
on a pu le voir à travers des minorités
qui c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
savoir dénoncer très rapidement alors
une association est monté au créneau en
tout au long de la journée
la licra par la voix de m galina elbaz
les présidents de la commission
discrimination de la licra écouter avant
de poursuivre ce débat on se rend compte
que ça touche maintenant des populations
qui sont elles mêmes victimes de racisme
ce qu'il y a de nouveau dans ce type de
propos racistes c'est l'évocation de
l'esclavagisme la traite négrière arabo
musulmane dans les livres d'histoire
c'est un phénomène qui passe un peu de
côté cette vidéo met en évidence un
racisme méconnu quand je vous dis ans ce
lien effectivement m gamme lina el baz
le fait avec une page de l'histoire peut
être méconnu il s'agit de la traite
orientale c'est un racisme méconnu c'est
un fait déjà méconnu ghislain veut d'eux
qui reçu orgie malencontreusement vue je
crois qu'ici il ne faut surtout pas
d'amalgamé je voulais rappeler que
beaucoup d'associations nord-africaine
et aussi qui défend les droits des arabo
musulmans nous ont contactés pour
dénoncer cela et dire que en aucune
façon cette personne ne représente la
communauté mais arabo-musulmane et nord
africaines ça c'est la première chose à
dire il ne faudrait pas tomber dans ces
amalgames et bien sûr pour dire les
choses crûment il ya des cons partout il
ya des cons qu'ils sont noirs et les
cons qu'ils sont blancs et des clans les
cons qu'ils sont juifs et des comptes
qui sont nord africain est donc cette
personne a commis une agression et aussi
des propos racistes qui sont
sanctionnables par la loi et donc il
faudrait pas faire d'amalgamé il ne
faudrait pas associer cette personne a
toute une ensemble tout un ensemble de
communautés qui n'ont rien demandé et
qui sanctionne cela dans leur majorité
alors on reparle de cet enseignement de
cette période de l'histoire n'avait pas
exactement répondu à cette question n'a
compris qu'il fallait pas d'amalgamé
nous on ne veut pas en faire sur ce
plateau mais on essaye quand même de
comprendre peut-être ce phénomène qu'on
ignorait peut-être que c'est un fait
isolé mais essayons d'approfondir
souvenez-vous notamment de cette petite
phrase de christiane taubira c'était en
2006 et compte et il ne faut pas trop
évoquer la traite négrière arabo
musulmane pour que les jeunes arabes ne
porte pas sur leur dos tout le poids de
l'héritage des méfaits des arabes nadir
khayat
quelle réaction alors moi je suis je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord moi je
suis pour la transparence totale
aujourd'hui on vit une époque très
difficile où les français s'affrontent
en permanence notamment à cause du jeu
malsain dead et du rassemblement
national et de certains médias
malheureusement qui ne donne la parole
qu'à ses extrêmes de droite et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut tous
diront vie n'est pas certes difficile
mais moi même en tant que français mais
également franco algérien maghrébins
musulmans
je suis pour tout dire
depuis la nuit des temps les esclavages
a toujours existé malheureusement toutes
les les toutes les grandes civilisations
ont eu affaire à ça malheureusement
et oui il ya eu des arabes qui est des
arabo-musulmans qui ont qui ont
participé à l'esclavagé s'il faut le
dire je le reconnais et nous en tout cas
moi en tant que musulman je le reconnais
qui on le condamne évidemment parce que
ça fait pas partie de notre religion
vous avez aussi des chrétiens et
d'autres communautés qui ont participé à
ça aussi malheureusement à des périodes
différentes
mais aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est
suffisamment mûre pour de se dire les
choses et tout cet ensemble pour
condamner ça parce qu'on est dans une
société multiculturelle avec des
histoires parfois différentes mais c'est
important aussi d'être tous ensemble
face à ce type de comportement
mais je pense aussi que pour compléter
ce que vous êtes en train de dire il
faut aussi heureux contextualiser alors
si on veut parler d'histoire remettre
dans un dans le temps et dans l'espace
et malheureusement quand on parle de
traite arabo musulmane c'est souvent
aussi pour masquer ce qui s'est passé en
occident aujourd'hui il nous faudrait
pas importer des débats qui devraient
être traités dans certains espaces pour
les importer en france aujourd'hui en
france c'est vrai qu'on lutte contre
toutes les formes de racisme on lutte
contre la traite négrière qui a eu lieu
entre l'europe la france l'afrique et
les amériques
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu aussi eu
cette traite négrière arabo musulmane
mais il faudrait pas se tromper l'espace
il faudrait pas se tromper de débat et
ici il ne s'agit pas de ce débat là le
racisme entre communautés c c'est
quelque chose qui n'existe pas pour vous
on à dire callas
c'est donc un fait rouler ce qui s'est
passé
cette fin des manches pardon non non il
y as je sais pas si le musée il ya
quelques années il ya eu des problèmes
dans 93 du côté de aubervilliers bobigny
avec des communautés asiatiques étaient
régulièrement agressé par des jeunes de
cité qui s'en prenaient à eux et qu'ils
pouvaient tenir des propos racistes
envers cette communauté
la réalité si vous voulez aujourd'hui
c'est de bien de réagir à un buzz et
condamner ce type de faits c'est très
bien mais à un moment donné il faut
aller au fond d'eux des problèmes et
notamment de la situation en france
maintenant si on veut régler ces
problèmes là il faut se dire tout il
faut se dire qu'aujourd'hui les
quartiers populaires c'est plus possible
de mettre des gens ensemble et d'imposer
un communautarisme et après de le
montrer du doigt en disant oui mais
regardez ces gens là sont très
communautaire alors que tout est fait
politiquement socialement et com - pour
que ces gens vivent entre eux il faut se
dire les choses aujourd'hui c'est le
plus possible il faut démanteler les
quartiers populaires il faut créer de la
vraie mixité sociale comme elle existait
dans les années 70 début 80 en france
il faut dénoncer les propos racistes qui
perdure aujourd'hui dans les médias et
qui sont devenus la norme de beaucoup de
politiques à droite comme à gauche
aujourd'hui et ces tensions rappelle
simplement cette situation que vivent la
plupart des français issus de
l'immigration ou pas aujourd'hui à des
choses qu'il faut savoir dénoncer pour
si vous voulez pérenniser le vivre
ensemble qui a existé à une époque et
qui est de plus en plus difficile
aujourd'hui parce que politiquement rien
n'est fait pour créer une vraie mixité
sociale à la hauteur des enjeux
lg c'est un aveu cette mixité sociale se
mélangent ça existait effectivement
avant aussi peut-être dans les cités ce
qu'aujourd'hui toutes les sortes de
communautés si j'ose dire ont du mal à
se mélanger peut-être elle se mélange
bien qu'avant qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est la cause aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui il faut faire
attention à la politisation du débat il
n'a échappé à personne qu'on est dans
une période pré électorale et donc que
ce genre d'incident va être récupérée
par les extrêmes et donc ce qui est
important de dire aujourd'hui c'est que
oui quand on met un maximum de personnes
paupérisée des personnes les plus
pauvres issus souvent de l'immigration
dans les mêmes environnements et bien ça
crée des tensions
et bien il ne faudrait pas pour autant
qu'on puisse cacher la réalité de ces
problèmes là aujourd'hui
des institutions qui font leur travail
il faut rappeler que quand les incidents
comme ça se passe comme ce qui s'est
passé hier
eh bien il ya des sanctions ce jeune
homme a été arrêté mais il ne faudrait
pas juste se concentrer sur ce jeune
homme
il ya un phénomène plus globale il faut
faire attention aux récupérations
politiques et ne faudrait pas justement
encenser ce genre d'événement pour ne
pas justement faire en sorte que les les
les personnes qui sont déjà à paupériser
puisse encore ressentir encore plus de
paupérisation
donc nous avons un devoir de
responsabilité francis un devoir de
responsabilité et notre devoir est de
rappeler qu'il faut se concentrer sur
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est de
rappeler que dans les quartiers à des
gens qui vit qui sont de toutes les
origines
blanc noir nord africaine asiatique et
que toutes ces personnes condamne cela
condamne cela mais j'en reviens à ma
question s'entendent aussi bien qu'avant
on dit souvent que le modèle
d'intégration à la française se déchire
un petit peu pour devenir un modèle à
l'anglo saxonne c'est ce que vous
constatez sur le terrain nadir khayat
pour en parler oui pour deux relais je
suis moi ce que je peux dire c'est que
plus on va vous redonner la parole au
geste avait demeurant on va laisser
effectivement répondu on vous donnera la
parole
globalement globalement les gens
malheureusement entre guillemets vis
très bien ensemble dans les quartiers
populaires après il peut y avoir des
périodes où il ya des tensions dues à
des faits divers mais globalement et
malheureusement ils vivent très bien
ensemble
mais aujourd'hui on impose ce vivre
ensemble dans les quartiers et donc il
peut il peut y avoir de temps en temps
des faits comme ça et comme l'a dit
monsieur très justement il y avait
récupération politique est aujourd'hui
la vraie question c'est comment on peut
on peut changer ça mais il n'y a pas de
volonté je vous donne un exemple assez
concret et je remercie arte france pour
nous avoir invités ça va faire deux
jours qu'il y à ce débat médiatique et
politique
et quand vous regardez les certains
médias ben vous verrez pas de personnes
issues des quartiers populaires vous
verrez pas de maghrébins ou de noir à la
télé pour parler de ces sujets là tout
en sachant que c'est les sujets qui les
concernent en premier
vous avez toujours les mêmes personnes
qui apparaissent dans les grands médias
et qui parlent de la banlieue sans la
banlieue ou l'immigration sans les
personnes concernées et c'est ça qui est
aussi violent en terme en termes de en
terme d'image de renvoyer cette
france-là kinky qui n'apparaît pas d'un
côté mais qui est de l'autre côté et
puis qu'on pointe du doigt donc je
remercie vraiment verte et france 2
la parole est de passer ce message aux
uns et aux autres
aujourd'hui dans les quartiers
populaires au delà de ce fait divers les
gens vivent très bien ensemble mais il
faut changer ça parce qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas imposer à des français issus
de l'immigration de continuer à vivre
comme ça dans des conditions qui sont
pas normales et qui sont injustes des
valeurs de la république notamment celle
qui est prônée par les politiques en
permanence au quotidien et dans les
médias j'essaye de le mot de la fin et
je vous laisse vous exprimer sur ce que
vous vouliez nous dire il ya quelques
instants
exactement on peut parler des quartiers
et moi je suis très bien plat par placé
pour en parler puisque j'étais éducateur
dans les quartiers pendant très
longtemps et dans les quartiers les
différentes communautés comme on les
appelle politiquement vivent très bien
ensemble et bien la question qui se pose
ici c'est toujours de quel point de vue
on parle de quel point de vue on part et
quand on donne la parole
systématiquement à des personnes qui ne
vivent pas dans ces quartiers et qu'ils
viennent instrumentaliser cette parole
là là il ya un problème
donc aujourd'hui effectivement y ait des
personnes ou si on va dans le xvième
si on va dans le 20e si on va dans le
18e si on va à sarcelles à cergy oui il
ya des agressions
oui comme ça se passe ailleurs mais
question qu'il faut sortir de cette
parole la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est de quel point de vue on parle à
qui est ce qu'on donne la parole
effectivement vous nous donnez la parole
pour en parler puisque nous sommes les
personnes concernées c'est une très
bonne chose mais ce qu'on regarde
politiquement par qui et
instrumentaliser ce débat on se rend
compte que ce débat n'est pas assumant
talise et par les personnes concernées
et je le rappelle les institutions font
leur travail et les personnes qui
commettent ces abus sont sanctionnés et
c'est ça qui est important de rappeler
mais surtout de dire qu'il ne faut pas
d' amalgame
merci en tout cas tous les deux jusque
là on veut donner
nadir khayat avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france